bonsoir nous sommes lundi 4 juillet
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal où
nous revenons comme chaque jour sur
votre actualité locale entouré de nos
invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite le sommaire de
votre journal michel rocard emblématique
de la classe politique française est
décédé samedi à l'âge de 85 ans celui
qui a incarné la gauche social-démocrate
a également été une figure du paysage
politique yves binois maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine de 1977 la 1994
sa disparition a suscité de nombreuses
réactions sur notre territoire nous y
reviendrons très largement ce début de
journal et retour sur la 100e édition de
l'open de golf à saint quentin en
yvelines avec la victoire sur le parc du
thaïlandais chung a aidé les 10 et celle
de rory mcilroy dans le coeur des
supporters un avant-goût de la ryder cup
2018 saluée par le secrétaire d'état aux
sports thierry braillard et enfin comme
chaque année depuis dix ans le 3 juillet
l'antenne locale d'amnesty international
à 50 ans on devine organisé sa balade en
liberté cette année la parole était
donnée aux réfugiés aux migrants venus
témoigner de leur parcours une
problématique toujours d'actualité et
nous ouvrons à cette édition avec les
hommages rendus à michel rocard l'ancien
premier ministre maire emblématique de
conflans sainte honorine de 1977 à 1994
est mort samedi 2 juillet à l'âge de 85
ans des suites d'une maladie
député des yvelines a dès 1969 sénateurs
de 1995 à 1997 il incarnait cette
deuxième gauche sociale-démocrate
ministre d'état dans les gouvernements
mauroy et fabius michel rocard entre à
matignon le 10 mai 1988 au début du
second set et n'a de françois mitterrand
il y restera trois ans à conflans sainte
honorine ville où il a exercé les
fonctions de maire pendant 17 ans un
grand nombre d'hommages lutte ont été
rendus devant la section socialiste
ils sont nombreux à avoir déposé des
roses comme vous voyez les habitants
aussi ont été très touché et ému par
cette disparition je vous propose de les
écouter quelqu'un de simple et de
de direct voilà qui en on a confiance
j'aimerais bien que le monde politique
lui ressemble un peu plus en ce moment
et voilà ça m'attriste mais c'est
quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup à cet
anneau mais très bien c'était bien bien
géré la ville de conflans c'est naturel
je ne suis pas socialiste mais je trouve
pour c'était quelqu'un de très bien très
franchement vraiment il a fait beaucoup
de choses et notamment le rmi qui était
qui a aidé beaucoup de gens en même
temps pour les peaux les fonctionnaires
il a été aussi très très très bien je
crois qu'ils aient toutes au dessus de
la politique qui vraiment je crois que
c'est vraiment ce qu'on retiendra de lui
principalement en fait et l'actuel maire
de conflans-sainte-honorine laurent bros
elle l'est républicain s'est également
exprimée suite à cette disparition il
était ce matin au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude à elle c'est une race
particulière en matière de culture
il a créé la médiathèque il a créé
également le théâtre simone signoret la
moderniser le conservatoire de musique
on se rend compte à travers les hommages
qui sont rendus ces derniers jours et
ces dernières heures encore que
finalement ces hommages sont issus de
toutes les sensibilités politiques
alors il a d'une certaine façon dépasser
les clivages
ces dernières années mais il faut quand
même se rappeler que dans les années 80
sans donner le maire est pas moins un
socialiste bien assumé et enfin la
municipalité de conflans sainte honorine
organise un rassemblement en hommage à
son ancien premier magistrat ce sera ce
soir lundi 4 juillet à 20 heures devant
l'hôtel de ville
la classe politique français s'était
également très largement exprimée suite
à cette disparition est à saluer l'homme
politique son engagement mais aussi sa
carrière pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental a salué la mémoire
d'un grand serviteur de la france mais
aussi l'un des français les plus humbles
dans un communiqué de presse à saint
quentin en yvelines les élus ont
également réagi et se sont souvenus de
lui je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions il a bien parlé
un parler vrai ouais c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours plu et qui me manque
aujourd'hui important de
de savoir dire les choses et de prendre
des décisions et surtout de savoir
s'engager malgré ce que l'on peut
attendre en retour il avait été maire et
ensuite il a été député il a été mis en
une limite sénateurs je veux dire c'est
quelqu'un qui a eu un parcours politique
d'une expérience incroyable et qui est
véritablement je crois travailler pour
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'intérêt
général dans les vignes de plus grande
partie des militants ont été re car bien
de soit de manière directe ou indirecte
c'est une fédération qui était d'avoir
au guardian qui s'est construit autour
aussi ce personnage tout à fait à partir
quitter michel rocard et donc oui vous
interrogez n'importe quel militant il
leur a toujours des anecdotes vous
raconter sur les campagnes qu'il a mené
avec michel ou sur des parcours qu'ils
ont eu en commun donc ces derniers
étaient actuellement marquante pour nous
c'est une grande tristesse parce que
pour moi c'était un ami et un patron
j'ai commencé mon apprentissage
politique avec lui au psu c'est un homme
d'une telle intelligence d'une telle
réflexion
j'aimais beaucoup son esprit son esprit
créatif et enthousiaste en même temps ce
qui manque beaucoup
il me semble aux nouvelles générations
en politique c'est plutôt un homme
simple sincère constructif constructif
c'était pas du tout un démolisseur comme
on a le marxiste qui veut vous détruire
l'entreprise le chef d'entreprise le
droit du travail ça nous étouffer
l'entreprise ça doit le mettre en danger
un prince me charles okah est le premier
homme d'état socialiste qui a osé poser
cette question il s'est même fâché avec
françois mitterrand souvenez-vous parce
qu'il ne voulait pas il voulait
justement que le parti socialiste garde
cet axe comme tous les partis
socialistes bien sûr européen de couper
avec cette vision très archaïque de
l'économie autre réaction écoutons à
présent benoît hamon il y parlait de
michel rocard sur notre antenne c'était
l'an dernier lors de l'émission à café
politique michel rocard influent lors
des premières années en politique de
l'ancien ministre michel rocard un homme
qui a été influent pour vous vous avez
été une surprise des relations d'atr du
mouvement des jeunes socialistes
et c'est michel rocard qui a donné un
petit peu débordante l'autonomie à cette
formation
c'est surprenant michel rocard c'est
plutôt libérale c'est à la veuve de la
gauche
non mais c'est heureux car et non mais
c'est pas ça c'est gros coeur c'est plus
et c'est honteux
auclair grossièrement quand on dit le ps
et le mitterrand la bouche on aurait dit
un héros car la droite
la réalité c'est que quand vous regardez
et vous le cool quand on lit quand on
prend le temps de lire
michel rocard on voit par exemple dans
la critique qu'il a de la
financiarisation de l'économie
de développement d'une forme de
capitalisme dévoyé et c'est qu'ils se
désintéressent finalement de l'outil
industriel pause se préoccuper que de la
rentabilité de l'action et du capital et
il a eu un discours très fort et des
propositions qui ont été très
importantes et quand on voit la place
qu'il a accordé lui à la question par
exemple climatique il a un des premiers
socialistes à cette emparé de cette
question là où honnêtement on a été nous
ma gauche ne très en retard de ce qui
était les prises de conscience dans la
société civile ou du côté d'europe
écologie les verts par exemple de
l'importance aujourd'hui de 2 du climat
et de l'environnement et pourquoi est ce
que c'est important d parce que
quand l'environnement se dégrade sa
touche au qui en première les catégories
les plus vulnérables et les plus
modestes
et pour ça que l'enjeu environnemental
c'est aussi un enjeu social et des
associations la rocard oui ça a été une
ça reste une référence mais pour la
gauche même pour ceux qui ont des
conventions collectives
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas envie depuis
longtemps vont être très honnête tu leur
trois dernière et ça reste une référence
intellectuelle que je respecte et avec
lesquels je conserve des points d'accord
évidemment et refermant à cette page
hommage avec un dernier extrait en
février 2011 michel rocard était
l'invité de patrice carmouze un échange
dans le cadre de la sortie notamment de
son ouvrage est si ça vous amuse
l'histoire de son parcours de ses
combats et de ses engagements écouter
l'ancien premier ministre parlait de la
social démocratie le courant qui
l'interné la france n'a jamais connu la
social démocratie et du coup elle ne
connaît pas le dialogue social
elle ne connaît pas les équilibres la
france vit avec des pulsions brutale
le front populaire la libération mais 58
on change à propos de l'algérie de
constitution mai 68 la france entière en
grève générale pour demander une autre
inflexion du pouvoir qui n'entend rien
politiquement mais qui entend beaucoup
culturellement et sociologiquement nous
ne sommes pas en social démocratie et
c'est dommage parce que c'est une
manière de s'adapter les uns au zoo de
s'écouter mieux sans brutalité
elle plus de progressivité tout autre
sujet à présent nous allons parler
sécurité dans le département vendredi
dernier à la mairie de versailles les
forces de sécurité de l'état les
services de police municipale ont signé
une convention de coordination une
signature entre le préfet serge morvan
et le maire françois de mazières qui
permettra de préciser la nature et les
lieux d'intervention des agents
municipaux en déterminant les modalités
de coordination avec la police nationale
et la gendarmerie
cette convention permettra également aux
agents le port d'une arme après avoir
suivi une formation
une décision qui a été prise suite aux
attentats survenus en france durant
l'année 2015 écouter cette annonce
permet effectivement
l'armement des policiers municipaux et
mai date de quelques mois déjà et mais
par contre c'est d'abord aussi la
volonté de la municipalité de la commune
de signer une convention avec nous c'est
aussi nous notre souhait pour que les
actions de la police municipale et des
forces de sécurité police et gendarmerie
sur versailles soit encore mieux
coordonner qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
souhaité que notre police municipale
soit armé c'est une décision qui n'est
pas facile mais elle correspond aussi au
soulier et des policiers municipaux
donc nous allons le faire dans des
conditions les meilleures avec un
processus de formation progressif est
évidemment destinée à ceux qui le
souhaitent il faut être volontaire dans
ce type de démarche
et puis nous aurons ensuite
le bénéfice des armes fournies par deux
miss aux matériaux et cela s'est déroulé
dimanche 3 juillet une marche pour
parler des réfugiés l'antenne locale
d'amnesty international à saint quentin
en yvelines organisé sa balade en
liberté avec des témoignages de migrants
et de réfugiés syriens burundais ou
encore à guinéen un moyen d'échangé
d'aborder ce sujet autrement également
de continuer à parler de cette
problématique nous y étions je n'ai pas
la nostalgie d'un exil qui me libère
d'une patrie d'une patrie qui pèse sur
mon souffle
colette lit en français ce poème
intitulé icilaba dallas mohammad la
réalisatrice et poétesse a fui la syrie
pour venir en france en 2012
aujourd'hui elle participe avec diane et
alassane à cette balade des libertés
organisée et initié par l'antenne locale
d'amnesty international à saint quentin
en yvelines en est né pour ça pour
communiquer pour vivre ensemble pour
dialoguer pour avoir
la profondeur c'est à dire l'autre c'est
notre miroir diane hakizimana venus
également témoigné partage elle aussi
son vécu journaliste au burundi elle est
partie de son pays en 2014 pour ne plus
y retourner laissant sa famille derrière
elle reporter à la radio elle dénonçait
la dictature elle risque la mort si elle
retourne un jour dans son pays d'origine
ça fait toujours du bien de partager ce
prix avec ce qu'on vit avec les autres
j'ai en moi c'est
c'est beaucoup quand partage c'est là
aussi on arrive à être enrichi à un
moment une initiative qui dure depuis
déjà 10 ans et permet de relayer les
campagnes message d'amnesty
international on parle de cette question
des réfugiés depuis déjà 2012 loi et
puis on compte c'est que c'est un combat
de longue haleine qu'il faut faire
prendre conscience aux gens que les
réfugiés sont des gens comme nous et
puis faire prendre conscience à nos
politiques que il faut qu'on quand on
accepte de les recevoir dans des bonnes
conditions
ce moment d'échangé ouvert à tous sera
reconduit l'année prochaine
le 2 juillet et ouvrons une page sports
à présent l'open de france a livré son
verdict ce dimanche le thaïlandais
tsonga et jay-z remporte l'édition du
centenaire avec tu es avec le quatre
coups d'avancé sur la concurrence il
devance l'italien francesco molinari et
le nord irlandais numéro quatre mondial
rory mcilroy
retour sur la compétition avec mité
halimi d'euros une surprise pour cette
100e édition de l'open de france tong
chaï jeddi 46 ans remporte le tournoi
avec une carte de 68 soit 11 coups sous
le par bach le sportif devance l'italien
francesco molinari de quatre coups le
golfeur devient par la même occasion le
premier asiatique à remporter cette
compétition depuis 1971 armes spatiales
week for men and women autres je pense
que ce week end était vraiment spécial
et c'était un grand week-end pour moi
c'est la plus grande victoire de ma vie
et remporter cette coupe était vraiment
fantastique
croyez moi je suis vraiment ravi de sa
c'est absolument parfait
parti à deux coups de la tête la
superstar de cet open de france rory
mcilroy n'a pas pu bousculer le
thaïlandais dans la dernière journée le
4e mondial signe une carte de 71 pour
terminer troisièmes à cinq coups du
leader
ça a été difficile de mettre beaucoup de
birdies les conditions n'étaient pas
excellentes pour le faire tong chaï a
joué de façon très impressionnante et je
pense que je n'avais aucune chance de
gagner
les derniers coups n'étaient pas trop
mal
oh je pense que je suis dans la bonne
direction du côté des français julien
quesne et mathieu decottignies lafon
terminé 16e ex-aequo et grégory bourdy a
lui fini 25e
le chouchou du public français victor
dubuisson terminant 66e et dernière
position de l'open de france avec une
carte de plus 17
son plus mauvais score en huit éditions
au golf national
le gouvernement français s'impliquent
pour la pratique du golf à deux ans de
la ryder cup organisée en france
au golf national et un mois des jeux
olympiques de rio traits tirés braillard
secrétaire d'état aux sports était sur
place ce dimanche 3 juillet à l'open de
france de golf il a signé avec jean loup
charron président de la fédération
française de golf la convention
d'objectifs s'il ira pour les années à
venir le ministère des sports et la
fédération
je vous propose de l'écouter c'est la
volonté de la fédération d'ouvrir ce
sport au maximum de jeunes filles et
jeunes garçons pour que plus tard ils
deviennent des vrais golfeur c'est un
symbole fort et puis dans quelques jours
les jeux olympiques avec pour la
première fois le golf comme sport
olympique
il y aura en 2018 la ryder cup qui sera
en france ici à 50 ans espère se nomme
un meilleur temps et puis 2024 l'accueil
nature de paris qui bien sûr intègre le
golf de saint quentin dans sa
candidature avec un joyau pareil c'est
un atout supplémentaire pour le dossier
le ministère des sports et la fédération
une convention d'objectifs hauteur de
620 6000 euros et 13 cadereyta sont mis
à la disposition de la fédération
française de golf
nous refermons à présent sept pages
sport avec un mot de cyclisme pour la
première fois à maurepas avait lieu la
journée tous à vélo samedi 2 juillet les
amateurs de cyclisme avait rendez vous
sur les routes et les bois de la ville
pour partager leur passion une journée
dédiée à la petite reine en partenariat
avec les associations
le cyclotourisme deux morales et l'âge
au vtt mélanie poquet et camille lambert
pour ce reportage
ans
les premiers pas à vélo un moment
toujours émouvant pour les parents
samedi 2 juillet à la fête du vélo de
maurepas samuel fait découvrir les
rudiments du cyclisme à son fils quand
on habite juste à côté on a vu les
différents stands donc bon on a voulu le
faire essayer de faire essayer de petit
vélo c'est sympa ça permet de découvrir
les différents taux de la ville parcours
de draisienne pour les plus petits ou
itinéraire en vtt pour les sportifs
pour cette première édition de tous à
vélo maurepas a souhaité créer un
événement adaptés à tous les niveaux
un moyen de sensibiliser le public un
loisir propre et populaire on est parti
en lien avec nos associations
le cyclotourisme maurepas et l'âge et au
vtt pour organiser une journée à
destination de la population où on
pourrait sortir notre petite reine et
l'utiliser pour parcourir notre belle
ville
on va aussi l'utiliser pour aller faire
des courses de proximité plutôt que de
prendre la voiture je crois que tout le
monde à y gagner
un village d'animations installé sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville a rythmé
cette journée une cinquantaine de
partenaires étaient présents pour
échanger avec les familles
notre activité c'est pas le tour de
france ce ne sont pas les chronos notre
activité c'est le plaisir sur le deux
roues le plaisir pour les jeunes pour
les moins jeunes pour les femmes
pour les enfants on est aux portes de la
vallée de chevreuse
on est tout à côté du massif forestier
de la forêt de rambouillet on est sur
les routes de la beauce avec ses beaux
moulin donc on a plein plein plein de
paysages à découvrir autour de maurepas
la journée s'est terminée sur la
compétition run and bike qui a réuni 28
équipes
plus de 500 personnes ont participé aux
différentes animations et pour finir
nous parlons transport à présent avec
nous en plateau arnaud bertrand
président de l'association plus de
trains bonsoir à vous bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors votre association regroupe des
habitants des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine vous êtes une association
d'usagers du transilien saint lazare
ligne aile et lui et vous militez pour
une 1 milliard sur une amélioration
rapide des conditions de transport temps
en temps de trajet quand fiabilité et en
sécurité
vous avez fondé l'association a plus de
trains 2013 suite un bilan
catastrophique c'est bien ça oui on en
avait assez en tant que l'usagé de
perdre beaucoup de temps en attendant
notre train le matin ou le soir on
pouvons pas rentrer pour relayer notre
nounou enfin vraiment des conditions qui
étaient difficiles et un moment à
plusieurs notamment éclater des réseaux
sociaux et puis on se rend compte 30 sur
les quais on s'est dit ça peut plus
durer donc on va se réunir tous ensemble
on prend le train tous les jours on est
capable de voir ce qui va pas et on va
aller voir nos élus on va aller leur
dire de nous aider à faire que la sncf
bouge et donc c'est comme ça qu'on a
lancé le mouvement en 2013 alors des
puits ya trois ans à votre combat evo
est maintenant vous êtes vous allez
commencer donc à 2,3 et une vingtaine
vous allez me gagner des victoires une
victoire on peut dire en décembre 2015
en décembre 2015
oui c'était l'aboutissement d'un long
projet en fait en 2013 donc quand on a
construit une association s'est vraiment
battu beaucoup les choses changent a été
difficile pour la sncf de se dire que
oui cette ligne aile qui va à versailles
qui va à saint nom la bretèche
fonctionnait vraiment mal et qu'il
fallait la remettre sur pied et donc en
décembre 2013 après beaucoup de
mobilisations des opérations de cartons
rouges sur les quais des élus qui sont
venus nombreux prendre le train avec
nous ils nous ont dit bon ben ok on va
essayer de changer les choses parce
qu'on aimerait c'est vrai que ça marche
très mal c'est vrai que les gens sur
tout le temps en retard que les trains
sont supprimés et on est rentré dans une
phase plus de construction
piloté par eux mais dans lequel on a
vraiment essayé de les pousser et de
travailler ensemble avec les élus locaux
avec le stif avec la sncf pour qu'en
décembre 2015 l'ensemble des horaires
alors c'est un peu technique mais
l'ensemble des horaires de sept lignes
ont bougé pour que ça fonctionne mieux
et en fait la sncf se mettait une
pression trop forte avec des erreurs qui
ne fonctionnait plus vu le nombre de
gens dans les trains et ça a quand même
sans changer tous les tiens sans
corriger tous les problèmes ça a aidé à
réduire les difficultés au quotidien et
c'est déjà un premier grand pas du coup
des horaires décalés mais plus de trains
justement après alors globalement pour
chacune des gares il ya plus de train ou
un peu plus de trains y en a qui en ont
beaucoup plus d'autres qui en ont à peu
près autant les l'ironie de l'histoire
c'est qu'en fait la sncf nous a dit
qu'elle en faisait circuler trop sur un
même créneau donc en fait elle en fait
sûr que les moins donc le nom notre
association ou plus de pain là dessus
c'est loupé en revanche il s'arrête un
peu plus dans les gares dont qui
permettent un peu mieux de faire des
relations entre banlieue à banlieue
notamment pour aller à la défense qui
est vraiment un endroit où beaucoup
beaucoup de gens veulent aller et donc
le pari là dessus et gagner
alors qu'est ce qui explique selon vous
mêmes avec la scène ça vous avez dû en
discuter
c'est aux consciences location très
difficile notamment sur les transiliens
écoutez ça fait trente ou quarante ans
que on a l'impression que c'est train là
ils sont ils ont été laissés comme les
étés les trains des années 70 c'est
toujours cela qu'on a aujourd'hui alors
évidemment à force de ne pas s'être
améliorée ne pas avoir modernisé la
ligne pendant des années de ne pas avoir
regardé le fait que les besoins ont
évolué il ya très longtemps voulait
aller à paris aujourd'hui on veut
toujours aller à paris c'est important
mais on veut aussi aller à la défense on
veut aussi aller dans les nouveaux
bureaux qui sont je ne sais où dans les
autres c'est nous à saint quentin en
yvelines
la géographie de l'ile-de-france a
beaucoup changé et ça ils l'avaient pas
fait donc on avait d'être un vieux on
les a toujours pour quelques années on a
des rails qui sont très vieux et puis on
avait ce qu'on appelle un plan de
transport la façon dont ça circule et
qui était plus organisés du tout les
gars de banlieue était pleine de monde
qui n'arrivait pas à monter et ça c'est
un peu un échec quand même c'est que
c'est resté beaucoup trop longtemps est
aujourd'hui rattrapé ce retard
ça prend du temps et donc nous notre but
c'est de les pousser à aller vite à
faire le plus vite possible parce qu'il
faut bien voir que la souffrance du
passager quand elle est quotidienne elle
devient très pénible pour tous ceux qui
doivent prendre ces troncs vous avez
justement tiré dernièrement un bilan
donc que ce que vous avez à communiquer
dessus les situations selon vous c'est
un petit peu améliorée quand même alors
nous noterons on est quelques fois on
est assez critique envers la sncf ou
envers le stif quand il bouge pas donc
ne la contrepartie c'est qu'on se dit
quand ils font les choses bien il faut
quand même qu'on le dise
alors c'est pas parfait cette refonte
horaire mais il ya quand même des vraies
améliorations et donc effectivement
depuis décembre 2015
il ya moins de retard il ya peu près
deux fois moins de trains supprimés deux
fois moins de retard et donc on a voulu
communiquer en disant que sur un certain
nombre de points c'était vraiment bien
ce qui était fait ça ne nous empêche pas
de leur dire par exemple de faire des
petites améliorations
je pense un sujet qui est anecdotique au
niveau de la ligne mais pas tant que ça
pour les collégiens et des lycéens
il y avait peu de trains pour arriver à
8 heures à versailles et la sncf ont
leur indice ça va pas parce que quand
vous en supprimer un les collégiens sur
systématiquement retard et donc à partir
du mois de septembre pour la rentrée ils
ont rajouté un train qui va permettre
aux lycéens et aux collégiens et ce
qu'ils sont nombreux
à venir de saint cloud de chaville et a
étudié à versailles d'avoir des
améliorations et on tient à ce qu'il y
ait ce suivi maintenant maintenant on
connaît la sncf ils nous connaissent
qu'on garde avec les élus à avoir une
relation proche pour pour continuer à
essayer d'améliorer le plus possible les
choses alors vous fonctionnez beaucoup
en dialoguant avec la sncf
vous faites aussi des opérations un
petit peu à carton rouge et vous êtes
très actif le réseaux sociaux c'est
votre manière de fonctionner alors nous
on a quelques principes il est il est
important quand ça va pas de le dire et
de le partager dans des médias comme le
vôtre auprès des élus on demande à la
sncf d'être dans une démarche
transparente alors on se l'appliquent à
nous aussi c'est à dire qu'on leur dit
voilà on dit aux médias ont dit aux élus
regardez les pointages tous nous on a
subi tant de retard on a subi 30 retard
sur le trimestre et c est quand ça va
pas quand on n'est pas content et bah
oui on fait des opérations carton rouge
sur le quais des gares
on invite les élus à venir prendre le
train avec nous quelquefois les élus qui
ont beaucoup de boulot ils ont ils
peuvent pas les prix sont pas là à 8
heures sur le quai avec nous et c'est
important qu'ils viennent que tu viennes
de la région qui sait des élus du maire
d'une ville prendre ce train voir dans
quelles conditions on est transporté
quelques fois le train circule bien ils
voient qu'il ya du monde mais ça va et
quelquefois ils se retrouvent avec nous
dans une belle pétaudière et là
généralement qui s'en souviennent
resterait transports sont une approche
très importante un petit où justement
les élus en ile de france
l'augmentation du passe navigo vous avez
réagi recommencer un sujet qui a fait
pas mal de polémiques comme valérie
pécresse a dit qu'elle me montrait
peut-être de 10 à 15 euros s'est dit
oulala c'est quand même un peu gros la
halle annonce qui a été faite une
augmentation de trois euros
passer de 70 à 73 euros c'est
significatif en revanche c'est vrai que
nous on se bat pour que les transports
soit fiabiliser qu'ils soient
modernisées et on dit qu'il ya eu
beaucoup trop de retard donc on leur
demande de remplacer nos vieux trains
qui ont 40 ans c'est vrai que ça coûte
cher
donc si la condition face à ces 3 0
c'est bien d'avoir des transports
améliorer un moment il faut être
réaliste il faut mieux en passer par là
et avoir des trains qui roulent plutôt
que de rester avec des pass navigo moins
cher mais des trains qui marche pas
parce que ça c'est vraiment pénible
comment on fait si on se fait justement
reçoit rejoindre votre ascension plus de
tracts donner son avis sur la ligne
alors si vous prenez le train sur la
ligne elle l'a eue sur le rer a aussi
parce que beaucoup d'usagers du rer a
mende et de les aider notamment à poissy
maisons laffitte à sartrouville et on a
élargi l'association vous nous contacter
sur les réseaux sociaux sur facebook sur
twitter ou sur notre site web
et on sera ravi de pouvoir élargir le
périmètre des référents par gars qui
sont vraiment nous sentinelle sur
chacune des gares pour voir ce qui se
passe pour travailler avec l'élu local
en question et poussé la sncf à
améliorer les choses
vous avez une enquête et moi parce qu'on
adore faire mais journal une prochaine
action prévue au mois juillet et oui
jean que justement la prochaine étape
c'est de travailler sur l'amélioration
de la ligne aile vers cergy et le rer à
vers poissy et cergy aussi c'est très
très difficile pour ces usagers là et
donc on va aller sur les quais à la
rencontre des passagers ont alors
demandé de venir nous aider de venir
témoigner pour que là aussi on puisse
pousser stif et sncf a amélioré les
choses durablement
merci beaucoup arnoux à bertrand d'at
venu sur notre plateau si vous souhaitez
rejoindre justement l'association plus
de trains n'hésitez pas à aller sur le
site internet et qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran merci à vous c'est à présent
la fin de cette édition je remercie nous
avoir suivis tout de suite vous avez
rendez vous avec michael elle me d'euros
pour le site sport il reviendra bien sûr
sur l'open de golf quand à moi je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée et vous
retrouve demain pour un nouveau numéro
du journal au revoir
il